>>> IT IS TIME NOW FOR THE GOOD
STUF
A SWIMMING COACH BEING HAILED AS
A HERO AFTER SAVING A COMPETITOR
FROM DROWNING AT THE WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
ANDY SCHOLES HAS ALL THE
DETAILS.
>> THIS WAS SUCH A SCARY SCENE
AT THE SWIMMING CHAMPIONSHIPS IN
BUDAPEST, HUNGARY.
THE IMAGES SHOWING WHAT COACH
ANDREA FUENTES DID.
INCREDIBLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
25-YEAR-OLD AMERICAN ANITA
ALVAREZ FAINTED DURING HER SOLO
ROUTINE AND SANK TO THE BOTTOM
OF THE POOL.
WITH THE LIFEGUARDS NOT REACTING
AT ALL, FUENTES DOVE IN TO SAVE
ALVAREZ.
ANOTHER AMERICAN SWIMMER JUMPED
IN AS WELL TO ASSIST ONCE
FUENTES GOT ALVAREZ TO THE
SURFACE.
SHE TOLD THE SPANISH NEWSPAPER,
I JUMPED IN TO THE WATER BECAUSE
I SAW THAT NO ONE, NO LIFEGUARD
WAS JUMPING IN, I GOT A LITTLE
SCARED BECAUSE SHE WASN'T
BREATHING.
THIS IS THE SECOND FUENTES HAD
TO JUMP IN FOR ALVAREZ.
ALVAREZ RECEIVED MEDICAL
ATTENTION POOLSIDE BEFORE TAKEN
AWAY ON A STRETCHER.
FUENTES POST